now do you hear any stories about those
places that's popular for swingers and
stuff because i would imagine here's
what i'm saying is if you're taking a
spouse out there if you're a man and you
have a female
side p sidekick with your wife you know
or whatever it is called
and i can't imagine y'all aren't doing
swinging and there's a lot of swinging
out there in the midwest too especially
in missouri
oh do you encounter any of that hey
do you hear any stories of it is there
any no actually
if there's mostly what i see is men that
are single out there picking up
the lot lizards okay you know and
they'll get what they want and then send
them on their way
and then they stop to the next truck you
know is it usually set or they is it
[ __ ] and is it oral sex do you know
what it is i don't even know
it just i guess it would depend on the
girl and how much money he wants to
spend
you know but yeah do you know the rates
on any of it how
no i wouldn't want to yeah because it's
literally like
you got to worry about them girls
sometimes because i've been told
that they can actually lay underneath
your trailer
and as you're coming out to say if
you're a man you're standing out there
taking a piss
they cut your ankles they can cut you
cut you in the back of that
just like hostile and that's
you got to watch them i've watched them
at night when i just pulled in and it's
two o'clock in the morning
and it's been raining i'll see you know
it's it's actually raining
there's a woman walking around a pair of
shorts and high heels
and she's tapping back well it's dark
can't really tell that helps but you see
her you know going from door to door to
door to truck to truck
truck and then the next thing you know
she disappears for about 20 minutes and
then she's out again
you'll see a light on in the truck
that's the dome then you know they tell
us
ah i know what you're doing uh-huh
and then she'll come out but i've seen
them walk
around the trucks like they're looking
for [ __ ] right
or maybe they're going to disconnect
something or pull something
you got to watch them because you don't
know what they're doing well they have
that famous documentary with eileen
warnos where she
wasn't she killing truckers no she
actually was killing just random people
that was picking her up
right she was prostituting herself out
and just randomly
picked out some dudes and do you see is
there any pimping or anything like going
on out there do you see anything like
that do you know who's approached my
trucks
and my truck is usually men drivers
other men drivers just wanting this now
are they asking specifically for sex
they're just kind of flirting or saying
i had a bosnian guy uh he told me he was
from bosnia
and uh he wanted to tell me how big and
beautiful my boobs were
oh and i was like okay okay you know
pretty cool i mean first of all that is
nice it was in maryland you know i'll
tell you this if a lady came up to my
window for no reason and said hey man i
like this yeah yeah well this is kind of
scary you know you're a girl in the
truck by yourself you're right
my bad you're right anyways he's
uh he sticks his body halfway in my
window
okay it's a beautiful day i had the
windows down which is stupid you don't
do that
so he put his head in the window he was
in his body was okay
the window up to halfway yeah i'm
standing there making up my bed you know
just kind of gonna stretch out or watch
tv yeah the window's open it's nice
beautiful day next thing i know i turned
around and i was like ah i screamed and
i was like
you could get a shot like that dude what
the [ __ ] get out of my truck
damn and he's like or not he wasn't bad
looking
now we're talking but it's a stupid
bosnia let me see where it is on a map
show yeah
check it out bring him in because i
asked him if he was rushing and he got
pissed at me
oh yeah they get upset he's like oh hell
no i'm not rushing we'll just wear a
sign that says bosnia and then dude
because it's like where are you from and
he's like bosnia yeah we hate russians
yeah they'll fight man they love to
fight russia yeah
um maybe google bosnian man
outdoors maybe but yeah he told me that
uh if
if he he would hate himself if he didn't
tell me that he wanted to
have a good time i was like roll on
alabama i
know no the bearded guy look at him
let's look at that guy down a little
third row no
i'll tell you what he looked like was
more like the the top roll up there and
third guy
that's the same guy but i mean that's
more like the picture
okay that's what he looked like wow
handsome kind of like you said a little
bit handsome
he was okay oh yeah but it was just too
weird man yeah it's a bit of a heavy
approach you know
you can't do the flake thing you know
it's kind of flaky yeah
yeah you can't just peek in my window no
yeah it wasn't a pubic
um it wasn't a peek it was not a peak it
was a full blown
wow i'm nipping your truck you got
yeah big beautiful was like oh my god
it's like i will hate myself if you not
have sex with me
in my truck did he say that yeah
basically yeah he wanted me to get out
and have sex with him in his truck
i was like get the hell out of here at
least he really laid it out you know
i guess exactly yeah because that's a
tough thing on this podcast we try to
encourage young men to like at least
shoot their shot you know but that's
kind of a shady way to do it well i'll
tell you some funny stuff too about
other
episodes this web we had a i was doing a
dedicated run which is the same thing
every day and i was leaving from our
shop which is in louisville
to um indianapolis ups okay
and coming back same thing every night
well started running into the same fella
that
in a car right up alongside of me just
grinning and
waving you know from his car and i'm
like hey how you doing
and i'm driving on you know next thing i
know he's blown his horn
so i glanced down and he's got his junk
hanging out oh wow
okay his penis huh yeah oh yeah wow then
he backs off
okay then he comes back up alongside of
me again he's grinning even bigger this
time
oh yeah his pants are down to his knees
this time okay
well i'm sitting here just driving you
know like literally wanting to put my
hand next to my face you know and just
kids here
because i'll slow down you know for them
to speed up a little bit then they'll go
back and then they'll
keep alongside of me the whole time no
matter what i'm doing oh yeah regardless
of the traffic that's going on around us
it's just you and them in the world
right it's like
a slow day i saw this guy five separate
occasions
same stretch of 65 in india indiana
and i named him jerk off jim oh yeah
he's out there huh he painted his
steering wheel
yes he did what color the
[Music]
that white glaze i bet yeah damn nasty
so you can now you can see his penis now
can you see from the tr from your
oh yeah it's the perfect view you can
see over to the driver's side
i can see everything wow inside of a
vehicle
a four-wheeler so if i'm driving right
and i have my penis
out yes can you and you're in a uh
in a rig yes how can you see my wiener
can you see it from
through the front window no it's from
the side of your side window the
passenger side you can see from the
passenger from over
me so you're passing me in the fast lane
i'm in the slow lanes two-lane highway
like i-65 is through indiana yeah i
could see everything inside of your
vehicle your back
seat front seat drive so if i put my
penis out you could see it i could see
everything that's awesome i could almost
count the hairs
oh wow
almost hell yeah i didn't know you had
such good size oh it's a hell of a view
it's the upstairs view from you know
seeing y'all from downstairs
good evening good afternoon and other
times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw i mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one
ah